where the waiting is over today
thousands of clark county students went
back to campus
it's the first day of hybrid learning
for all middle and high schools
elementary students are now back in the
classroom five days a week starting
today
hector mejia shows us how they all
returned
it's sort of a mixed bag across the
district some campuses are reopening for
the first time in more than a year while
others are bringing back more grade
levels like neil steam academy here
in the northwest melinda right here mama
wave we always hug or give each other
high five
she went on in and i i feel a little
hurt but
this is safe april 6th felt like the
first day of school for so many just ask
grandmother linda palmer
her fourth grader melinda is back in a
classroom for the first time since the
pandemic disrupted classes
she's like i'm gonna miss you granny
i'm gonna be good she said i'm ready i'm
ready
and i said okay it's the first day all
elementary grade levels at ccsd can
return to
five days of in-person learning capacity
also
increased up to 75 percent
over at centennial high school this red
carpet arrival
marked the occasion underneath this
bulldog mascot
a 10th grader who heard it all ranging
from the excitement
to the jitters i heard kids like where
do i go
i don't know where to go so it's kind of
like everyone's just new to this
believe it or not luke anderson says
he's just happy to see his teachers
again
i was like a straight a student then
online grades kind of drop
for now middle and high schools will
stick with hybrid learning
the goal is for all grades to return
full time in august
according to ccsd superintendent dr
jesus jarrah
kovet is there is no telling in the
northwest valley hector mejia
8 news now